hundreds of ultra right-wing Israeli
nationalists have made incursions into
Alexa mosque compound at the start of
Israel's so-called Flag Day among them
were a number of current and former
Israeli ministers and members of the
classic access to the compound used to
be coordinated with the Palestinian
authorities but that's not happening
anymore many Palestinians see this as a
provocation
the Palestinians in occupied East
Jerusalem have been forced to close
their shops Israeli settlers standing
alongside Israeli forces were seen
attacking Palestinians in The Old City
several arrests were made
on this day Israelis Mark the 1967
capture of occupied East Jerusalem by
holding marches the old city is not
internationally recognized as part of
Israel despite Israel annexing it the
Marx is at Damascus gate and occupied
East Jerusalem where the Flag Day March
is going to be passing in about an hour
or so what's it like there so far Willem
we're of the natural Auditorium around
Damascus gate behind me is already
filling up with hundreds of people you
can hear them many of them waving the
Israeli flag some of them sitting there
very simply watching events unfold
there's a significant police presence we
just spoke to one of the spokespeople
for the Israeli police here in Jerusalem
he told us there were 3 000 officers on
the streets today over the course of the
last few hours we have seen some
scuffles some altercations between
individuals on both sides of this
obviously long time divide and at the
moment I have to tell you it's
relatively peaceful
we have seen very tense and indeed
violent situations where you are at
Damascus gate in the past Al Jazeera has
been covering those it does as you say
seem to be different this time why is
that
well certainly over the course of the
last two or three hours when we were
inside the Old City just off to the side
of me here we did see young Israelis
Ultra nationalists marching through the
area in small clusters occasionally uh
provoking talking to shopkeepers some of
them ended in scuffles many of the
Palestinians that we spoke to over the
course of that little walk about told us
they were sweat resigned to this
situation while they're upset that
they're having to close their businesses
often five hours early to normal and
they're losing customers and therefore
income many of them told us there wasn't
a huge amount they could do they do feel
that this is an occupied City they do
resent the fact that these young people
can't many of them young people I should
say and taunt them in their place of
work in a place where many of them have
grown up and lived and worked for many
decades but at this stage they said it's
safer for them to go home and avoid some
of the potential violence we've seen in
previous years Willem just briefly tell
us what is going to happen next because
as you say the the uh bearers are
gathering in the kind of amphi theater
that you were talking about outside
Damascus gate what happens next once
they have gathered into what they regard
as a large enough crowd
well we expect that much larger numbers
of people are going to flood into this
area behind me the police have
constructed a series of walls and fences
to try and funnel the marches in a
specific Direction they'll come down
into this space you can see there's a
huge number of police around here so we
expect that there will just be more
singing more dancing perhaps what they
would call celebrating of this this
national day here in Jerusalem the
concern the police have and many
Palestinians inside the old city have is
that some of those individuals will then
go inside the parts of the old city
where there may still be some businesses
open and that could lead to increased
tension as well Villa marks talking to
us from Damascus gate in occupied East
Jerusalem